سنذهب للخارج الآن إلى Polo
Sandoval من CNN في بوفالو نيويورك ، أعني
Polo wow whiteout حيث
أنت مثل
كريستين يمكن لمشاهدينا أن
يصوروا الجاموس في الشتاء ومن المحتمل أن
يجدوا هذه الصورة وهذا هو بالضبط ما
يحدث  في الوقت الحالي بالنسبة للعديد من
السكان ، نحن على بعد 40 ياردة تقريبًا
من الكاميرا وقد مشيت
هنا حتى أتمكن من
إظهار أكبر مصدر قلق
للسلطات في الوقت الحالي وهو ضعف
الرؤية لأولئك الذين يقررون ذلك
حاول شجاع الشوارع في وحول
مدينة بوفالو ، وسأسير ببطء
نحو أه زميلنا توم جوريك
خلف الكاميرا هنا لأننا في
مكان آمن نسبيًا حتى نتمكن
من إظهار ذلك لك نظرًا لعدم وجود
القليل  لا توجد حركة مرور بالفعل لساعات ، فقد
أحصينا ربما ثلاث مركبات
مرت هنا ، لذا فمن المؤكد
أن الناس يستجيبون للتحذيرات
من مسؤولي مقاطعة إيري
بحظر القيادة المطبق هنا
بشكل أساسي  نوصي بأن
حركة المرور الأساسية فقط بسبب حالات الطوارئ
تحدث الآن ولكن يجب أن
أخبرك أنني غطيت العديد من الأعاصير التي
غطيت بها العواصف الاستوائية التي غطت العواصف الشتوية
ويبدو أن هذين الاثنين
يتقاطعان اليوم هنا في بوفالو هذه
هي الظروف التي
سنستمر حتى الليلة ومن
المحتمل أن يكون لدينا غدًا
تأثير البحيرة هذا ، ويبدو أن هذا ليس
صانع ثلج ضخم صدق أو لا تصدق
أن الرياح هي التي تدور حول
كل الثلوج التي تساقطت ثم
تضيف إلى ذلك الفلاش  التجميد الذي
سنستمر في رؤيته طوال
الليل حيث تستمر درجات الحرارة في
الانخفاض لكريستين ،
مرحبًا ، لقد كان مذهلاً لم أكن
أتوقع أنه لم أكن أعرف على الإطلاق
أنك ستكون في اللقطة التي
لم أتمكن من رؤيتك فيها  كل شيء وأنت
خرجت للتو من تلك العاصفة الثلجية ، أعني
أنها تظهر لك حقًا مدى انخفاض
ظروف الرؤية في مكانك